well also a lot of people don't know and
you don't [__] know this either is my
mom had some other properties that she
owned like she owned a place called The
Pickle Barrel
a lot of people don't it was literally
across the street you know back in the
day there was the tarot card reading
place right across you from the store
yeah well before that year yeah before
that was a place called The Pickle
Barrel
so my mom I'm gonna buy a place because
just we're just gonna have pickles and
it's not really yeah there's pickles
from all over the world she had pickles
from hungry like this from Poland so as
a kid my mom always made me shut up and
she'd said she'd stick a pickle on my
[__] hand bro with like a napkin
she's good just shut them up put a
pickle in his hand so as a kid I
remember I always had a [__] pickle
in my hand why does that make you be
quiet because I'm eating a pickle in my
hand I mean you know when how long and
then what happened to The Pickle Barrel
it went it wasn't happening my my
daughter [__] it up what Sandy [__]
it up I think she managed it or
something like that Sandy had the pickle
place was going even when The Comedy
Store was going I don't remember the
scene I know that's what I'm saying a
lot of people don't remember it was an
undercover secret like Speakeasy Pickle
Place no it's a real like customers
would come in and buy pickles it just
didn't do so hot did that did that
building become part of the comedy store
later
reading place
did you own the tarot card reading place
no just because she just had the pickles
yeah and then she had Ty us which was uh
Thai food this was before before the
House of Blues right across street from
you know the store yeah there was a uh
it was called I forgot the name of the
the cool like Hollywood restaurant but
my mom bought it from that that was like
a Ryan O'Neal used to go and all that my
mom bought it and she started a Thai
restaurant and it was called tyus and I
just have Thai food yeah tie us and then
next ordered pickles yeah no the tyus
was right after that oh the pickles
closed yeah she she trans uh she
transcended from pickles to Thai yeah
okay maybe that's your love of Asians
yes is it probably but then also a lot
of people don't know if she had a
theater in um in uh in Hollywood on the
corner of Las Palmas and Sunset and she
called it the Richard Pryor theater do
you remember that I do I didn't know it
was hers yes so she started that and she
had a motel next to that so she started
buying all this [__] and you know and
then she I'm gonna get this this hotel
for Richard he's gonna work on all his
stuff and yet Richard never went once to
it to theater never once that's how much
my mom loved Richard tell us a Richard's
story that nobody knows in in the house
like or that well you know one morning
you know I was making my Cheerios
downstairs and he says and he started
walking by man sorry man I'll see you
later weasel and he just took off no I'm
just kidding no um I think they had sex
but that's another story did your mother
have a have a I think some affair with
Richard yeah why do you think I don't
know I don't know if it was an affair I
think they probably just humped you know
she was humping everyone
she was like the Humpty Dance bro the
Humpty did you have sex with his mom no
yeah no I didn't I brought you on to say
you are my son no but I don't know that
she was having sex with everyone but she
was a she was a she like she dated
Comics yeah I remember one morning
actually a couple mornings waking up in
James leveries was at the [__] house
who James Lee Reeves I don't know who
that is like the country comedian he had
the curly hair he had all his [__] in
the Box almost like Gary mildeer kind of
like that no I remember Ollie Joe Prater
yeah I don't remember she didn't do
Ollie Joe prayer no so did that bother
you or did that that
yeah it bothered me yeah for sure you
know it bothered me because they were
using her obviously you know what I mean
but you know she was using them too so
it was like a big use Fest I guess you
know wow
[Music]